pull up uh what Davos is meeting here
and what they said is the crisis they're
most worried about two years versus 10
years okay so these are the things they
put out just recently what things to be
worried about two years versus 10 years
in the two-year side World economic
Forum uh you will see at number 10
pollution then economic downturn then
involuntary migration in voluntary
migration then inflation lack of
Economic Opportunity Interstate armed
conflict Rob can you zoom in a little
bit cyber security number four and then
you have uh uh social uh polarization
societal polarization extreme weather
events and number one is what
misinformation and disinformation of
course because of election yeah